hey you guys time once again for my
flickers of fears my little movie review
series that i do on the side here
so let's talk about
david bruckner
now i had come across his work several
times before he actually directed
segments in a bunch of anthology like
horror anthology movies the signal which
was actually kind of less than anthology
is kind of like two or three like i
think it was just two stories uh he also
did one in vhs
and southbound which is really good
and he was also the guy that directed
the excellent 2017 movie the ritual
which was based on a book by adam
neville now despite knowing all of that
and having seen all of those things
i hadn't actually heard about it's not
actually his newest film but it's one of
his newer ones but i hadn't actually
heard about his movie the nighthouse
until i was watching on shutter they
have the fangoria um chainsaw awards
like for 2022 where they were giving the
awards to movies that came out in 2021
and i noticed that this movie the night
house had been
uh nominated in a whole bunch of
different categories i don't remember if
it won any of them but it was like you
know best lead performance best movie
best stuff like that and i was like oh i
hadn't heard of that one so i was just
kind of like oh it sounds really good
it's a haunted house story kind of and
it had rebecca hall in it and i actually
really like her so i figured hey i'll
give it a whirl it's actually on hbo max
which is where i watched it
now i will say that the movie actually
kind of did the festival circuit back in
2020 but it didn't get a wide release
until 2021 so i until like late summer
of 2021 so i guess it's like considered
so like a 2021 movie even though it
actually premiered a while back
now the screenplay was actually written
by his you know oft
writing collaborators uh ben collins and
luke uh piotrovsky i think is how you
pronounce his last name uh they were the
guys that also wrote the uh the movie
super dark times which came out in 2017
which is also really good this movie was
i mean it's just like has atmosphere for
days man it's just kind of like it's
sort of a go it's a ghost story and it's
also like a supernatural mystery and i
just got sucked into this like right
from the get-go
i have to say too that rebecca hall's
performance is actually really elevates
this movie um it's kind of like
she's just very the the range of
emotions that she has to portray is just
really incredible it's just you know
this kind of very just raw very nuanced
um and very kind of real feeling uh you
know characterization and she really
really brings it and she really like
makes this into something special i mean
like i said this is kind of like
if you're into like really eerie like
low-key type of ghost stories not a lot
of jump scares or anything like that
it's more like mood and atmosphere but
like creepy [ __ ] does happen in it um so
don't go into it think it's not gonna be
some like big action-packed whatever
this one is just like a real eerie
low-key haunted house type story which i
actually really like those so i actually
enjoyed this like quite a lot so rebecca
hall plays our main character whose name
is beth now she's a high school teacher
and her husband owen who was an
architect
just a few days prior to the events of
the film he has actually committed
suicide he went out on this row boat
like on the lake that's sort of like
adjacent to their house and essentially
just like blew his head off with a gun
that she didn't even know that he owned
so because of this uh beth is
understandably uh quite distraught she's
very confused she's very angry um she
doesn't really know what to do with
herself
now school has just let out for the
summer so she had like a few days uh off
like obviously for the funeral and stuff
like that but she goes back to work like
at the beginning of the summer to turn
in her grades like with the rest of the
teachers
and when she comes back in there like
she's a little bit late and the way
everybody looks at her is just being
like okay that's a little weird like her
husband just shot himself and she's back
at work after a couple days everyone
thinks well this is probably not good
because it's like too early and her
friend she has like a close friend who's
also a teacher named claire
who is kind of like a major character
going forward and she's very worried
about beth and she tells her that but
beth is like well i just had to
i have to be doing something normal
you you know to take my mind off of the
situation but you can tell that she's
not really all that okay she's not
really dealing with it all that well she
has kind of like a fraught uh
conversation confrontation with like a
sort of a disgruntled parent later on uh
where she just kind of
uh kind of unloads on the lady who's
kind of being a little bit of a karen uh
so there's kind of that and she kind of
goes out drinking with some of the other
teachers and you know it ends up being
really awkward for everyone involved
because she's kind of like acting like
she's dealing with it but she's
obviously not really dealing with it all
that well probably not helping her
mental state all that much is the lake
house itself as i mentioned her husband
shot himself right out on the lake uh
she's still living there for the time
being
though uh she tells her friend and
neighbor who just lives like you know
down the coast or whatever uh his name's
mel and she says she's considering
selling it
now she feels kind of bad about it
because her husband like i said was an
architect so he actually designed and
built this house
and there's still traces of him like all
over it
but on the other hand it is kind of like
isolated and lonely it's sort of like
out in the woods a little bit and the
rowboat where he died is still there so
it's just out there kind of like bumping
against the dock like every now and then
so she has to like see it like every
time she goes outside like to go to work
or whatever so beth uh spends a few
nights after owen's funeral basically
just like sitting on her couch drinking
herself into oblivion and you know
watching videos of him in happier times
or whatever so like i said she's not
really dealing with it all that well
very slowly though uh weird little
things start happening in and around
this lake house
she hears what could possibly be a
phantom gunshot echoing across the lake
for example one morning she sees these
muddy or bloody uh bare footprints on
the dock that are gone a little while
earlier it looks like somebody came out
of the water and walked up the dock but
then like a couple hours later they're
gone
uh the stereo turns itself on like
playing one song in particular which is
called the calvary cross
beth starts having really really weird
dreams that she can't she doesn't really
know if their dreams are not because
they seem like very realistic
uh she also starts sleepwalking now she
said that her husband owen used to do
that but she never did but she says now
that he's dead like she's starting to do
it too like sometimes she'll wake up in
the morning and she'll be like in the on
the bathroom floor or like on the floor
of her husband's office or something
like that and it's getting to be a
little bit weird so during one of these
purported
dreams nightmares that she's having
she gets a text message from owen's
phone
and it basically says like she hears
knocking at the front door she goes to
the front door and there's nobody there
but she gets like a text message and
it's basically telling her like not to
be afraid and to come downstairs
and it seems like completely and totally
real and she's like freaking out
thinking like owen has like come back to
haunt her or whatever
but then the next morning when she looks
at her phone the text messages are not
there so she's saying well maybe it was
a dream after all but she's not entirely
convinced so what she does is she goes
out to i guess she's been keeping sort
of like the police evidence box like in
her car that had like all his bloody
clothing and the gun and everything like
that they gave it to her like after
um and she hasn't really gone through it
yet i mean again understandably
so she goes in there and digs around and
gets his phone out
and looks to see if the text messages
were sent from his phone and they
weren't they're not there
but
when she's going through his phone just
kind of out of curiosity
she comes across a very odd photo of a
woman in it looks like a bookstore or a
library or something like that now the
photo looks like it's been taken from a
little bit of a distance away like from
somebody that was just like watching her
but she didn't know the person was there
and um it's sort of taken a little bit
from the back so you can really kind of
see like the side of the woman's face
and her hair and like her hand is kind
of up like that
now at first
beth is looking at it and she thinks oh
maybe this is like a candid shot that
owen took of me because it's the same
kind of hair and everything like that
but then she starts looking closer and
she realizes that it's not her it's
another woman that only kind of
resembles her because she's like you
know yeah that looks like maybe she's
like i don't have a blouse like that and
you know it's definitely in the
background doesn't look familiar
now she tells her friend claire about
this she's like look at this woman
that's not me and claire is like well
yeah but it could be you though you know
what i mean and you know so they kind of
have a little bit not an argument
necessarily but like i said claire is
worried
claire basically begs her look um you
know finding uh
just a photo of a random woman and she's
like not even naked or anything like
that she's just like standing at a
bookstore she's like there's certainly
way worse things you can find on your
husband's phone um just please stop
worrying about it she's like it even if
the photo isn't of you if it's just some
random woman then what good will it do
to like just dredge up the secrets you
know your husband's dead and you really
need to go on with your life just
remember that owen that you loved and
just stop looking into it like for the
sake of your own mental health which
seems like good advice but of course
beth cannot let it go
i mean the thing about it and like i
said understandably she's obviously
filled with a lot of grief it was very
surprising what happened but she's also
very angry at him i mean because she's
like what the [ __ ] like why did you do
this to me it's like she had no idea
that he was even depressed or anything
because she says to her friends she's
like that was my thing like i was the
one that struggled with depression he
always seemed like he was the one that
was always pulling me out of it and she
even kind of makes sort of like a joke
but not like about maybe i infected him
with my depression or something like
that she said it was completely
unexpected she didn't even know he had
the gun or anything like that so she's
like really really angry she doesn't
know the reasons behind it and so she
really really wants to get to the bottom
of it even though it's obviously very
upsetting for her
she's also tormented by this very
terse and cryptic
note that he left her like suicide note
it's basically just four lines and says
something like you were right there is
nothing
um and then it says i can't remember
what the third line was but the last
line was you're safe now
and she tells claire she's like well i
kind of know
what the first part of that means but
it's like i don't really know what
you're saved now it's just like i don't
really know what that means but she
knows what a couple of the other things
mean though but it's still like pretty
weird
so
beth starts investigating further into
like what the [ __ ] did he have some
whole secret life that i'd even know
about because i didn't think that we had
secrets from each other but apparently i
was wrong because all this [ __ ] was
going on
so as she investigates further looking
into his phone and things like that she
finds even more mysterious photos of
women who sort of look like her they're
not it's not a kind of thing where it's
like oh they're naked or anything or
it's porn or anything like that it's
sometimes
sometimes they're just kind of like
candid shots um sometimes they're just
like you know just a regular portrait of
like a woman smiling like on a dock or
something like that and sometimes
they're taken from like far away but
they all
kind of look like her you can tell that
it's not her but they all just kind of
have like longish dark hair like she has
she also finds hidden like in this box
behind a bunch of other books and things
like that she finds like a bunch of sort
of like disquieting uh books
about the occult
that owen has made notes in
she also finds there are some
architectural plans for a house
that is essentially an exact mirror
image of their own house like the one
that they've been living in
uh which is really weird and there's
like some [ __ ] about mazes and trickery
and stuff like that and she's like what
the [ __ ] was this dude like into
uh you know the dreams and the
sleepwalking continue beth sort of
starts
getting to a point where she can't
really tell like what really happened
and what really didn't um she looks
across the lake one night and thinks she
sees another house over there like she
sees like a light in the window and when
she asks mel he's like yeah there's no
house there it's just like it's county
land you're not allowed to build on it
or whatever but he kind of knows a
little bit more than he that he's kind
of letting on too
uh so yeah so she starts seeing [ __ ]
like that and she's there's a lot of
stuff about like reverse mirror images
and she sees kind of some
sort of shadowy i don't want to call it
like a shadowy figure it's kind of like
a like a silhouette that looks kind of
like a person but not like from a
different angle it's actually like
really cool but yeah so there's all that
kind of stuff so the mystery of the
movie comes from
what exactly was owen up to like why
did he kill himself when beth had
absolutely no
reason to think that he would do
something like that is owen maybe
haunting the house like because he's
trying to tell beth what was going on i
mean somebody's haunting the house for
sure like there's some weird ghosty [ __ ]
going on or
is it him is it something else is it
something more sinister is there some
other plot that needs because for sure
there was some kind of [ __ ] going on
with owen that she absolutely knew
nothing about
so as the movie goes on like the mystery
gets like deeper and deeper and it gets
like kind of thornier and murkier
and it perhaps has something to do i
want to spoil too much about it because
i feel like maybe a lot of people
haven't seen this one yet but it could
have something to do with linking back
to something that beth told claire
earlier that when she was 17 years old
she had essentially like a near-death
experience or she was in like a really
bad car accident she was dead for like
four minutes
and she's telling her that you know
people ask me all the time but what did
you see like after you died you see like
the tunnel of light and everything and
she says something like i didn't see
anything she's like um it wasn't a
tunnel she said something like it wasn't
a tunnel of light it was just tunnel
like there was nothing there so um so
that kind of does play into the story
like later on
so as i mentioned i'm really glad that i
ended up hearing about this like i said
i just i wouldn't probably have heard of
it necessarily um unless i was watching
that shutter uh you know fangoria
chainsaw awards show because that's also
where i heard about sensor and come true
and like some other movies that i've
watched recent in the earth like ones
that i watched recently that i really
liked and this was definitely one of the
best ones it's very it's outstanding um
it's very slow burn like i said it's
kind of like a mystery or like a
supernatural thriller but it is a ghost
story you know what i mean
um and it has like this really complex
and really really interesting compelling
mystery like at the center of it as i
said there are very very few jump scares
there are a couple it just kind of like
drips with this really creepy atmosphere
i think like one of the best things
about it was just like the way that
the ghost sometimes like appears it's
almost kind of like this it looks like a
human silhouette like in the
architectural details of the house like
sometimes she'll turn around and she'll
see
like what looks like a like a shadow
silhouette in sort of like a little
doorway or some kind of like molding or
something like that but then when she
moves like that like it's gone again
like the angle it's like really really
good it like plays with like angles and
mirror images and stuff like that and
it's like really unsettling so i really
liked the way uh the way that came
across and i didn't really i feel like
the mystery is so
this definitely needs like a second
watch the mystery is not complicated
necessarily but there's a lot of moving
parts to it there's like a lot of kind
of details i don't i don't know i guess
it's not that complicated like i kind of
got where it was going but i mean i
didn't really guess exactly where it was
going but
it was it was a little bit of a surprise
like at the end like what
what the aspect of the mystery was that
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like it's hard to say like without
spoiling it but yeah yeah so if you're i
mean if you're looking for something
like really gory or really super fast
paced or action-packed or anything like
that then this is not for you
but if you're really into
really creepy kind of slow burn ghost
stories
that have like um like a really weird
like supernatural mystery at the heart
of it then you should really dig this i
think um it's really
it's actually kind of it's kind of like
a very thoughtful
sort of like a puzzle box ghost story
and rebecca hall was like great at the
center of it i think she really really
conveyed what you know what a person
would react like if there if something
like this had happened if their husband
like suddenly like committed suicide and
you had no idea why and then you were
finding out a lot of the like rage and
stuff like that like comes out really
well but she still
obviously like loves and misses this man
as well because of all of the they had
been married for 14 years i think she
mentions so it's kind of like this
it's just like a really really great
like emotional performance and i thought
she was like really fantastic in it so
yeah if you're really into ghost stories
this is on hbo max at the moment uh so
check it out it's really good i liked it
uh quite a bit and that will do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one
bye